okay I wish I were meeting here in
Jerusalem given the topic of our
comforts what will save the world a
Jerusalem is a quite few years place in
Jerusalem where is this claim that they
know what will save the world right the
Messiah the new Messiah the return of
the Messiah Judaism Christianity Islam
what's your take on that
that that we know what will save the
world there is something which is called
The Jerusalem syndrome do something
Lizbeth there is a certain kind of
madness which is associated with Jews
and really met people coming with
visionary ideas about a sort of global
eschatological I guess and they really
go raving mad it's it's document it's
not just it's a name by now I think of
genuine exchanging disease so you
basically asked me to be to talk like
someone with a Jerusalem syndrome first
of all I don't think that the world is
in danger I don't think that the world I
think basically the world is safer now
than it was 50 years ago the polarity of
this whole new clue when people really
were terrified of new clothes
talk about terrorism is overblown
basically not that there is daughter and
unless you call terrorism is every
organization that you dislike but if by
terrorism you mean sort of yeah there
will be mortar on a rittle basis but
it's not a danger
don't believe that tourism can stop
let's say but the Pirates did in the
Mediterranean they stopped let me did it
Iranian trafficking before for four
hundred years
Ivan is I don't think that anything of
that sort is about to happen
I'm not neither cultural pessimist and
not an optimist facto I don't see the
world it will be a different world the
people like me he won't find maybe
congenial maybe not but at least strange
and not that we are not I'm not
adaptable already to to the gadgets the
tournament the point main thing is
whether the Guttenberg Revolution
Gutenberg namely the printing culture is
about to disappear and be replaced by
something else in some sense it's
already happening on the other hand
people with no looks now than ever then
of course the issue of the climate
change which I believe is Israel so say
if saving the world is saving the planet
in the sense of doing something about
climate change or what can be done
that's that's a that's a serious problem
I don't believe that it can be done with
the basis mainly in the video we try to
do to behave it's really for the big
powers to negotiate named the United
States China mainly and so India places
open well that series but that's about
it namely in terms of really what I find
is in danger I don't think that I will
be the civilized ever the civilizations
will be transformed
we'll be transformed mutate and some of
us like the direction in which it was
some of us not I hear more pessimism
around me I know that I'm surrounded by
people like me are simply aging and it's
a syndrome about us and not about the
world